so how exactly is this gonna work we're
sort of thinking that you'd have to have
a specialized electric skate on which
cause would run but that actually ended
up being quite a quite a complicated
solutions now we've come up with I think
quite a clever idea which is to have
retractable wheels so you take a normal
car like a like a Tesla it is Tesla it
what doesn't need to be electric so it
doesn't create fumes and consume oxygen
but combustion car creates fumes and
consumes oxygen so you can't have that
in a tunnel we've created
they're almost like airplane landing
gear they go out sideways to the side of
the tunnel and they brace the car
against the tunnel but then those wheels
can retract and it can drive on the road
so you have it you have a car that can
drive on normal roads and then can also
drive essentially on it on the track in
the tunnel can only people that have
Tesla's use your tunnels
well it'll be any any car that is needs
to be electric autonomous and then and
then fitted with these wheels but will
enable it to be fitted with any
manufacture will be able to have the
sort of wheel kit added to their car
it's not just limited says the